it's fun we just got hassled by the LAPD
on the way to the studio two cops pulled
us over an Asian guy and a bald guy and
uh we had inched over the line what was
it the line of the the traffic line the
intersection line now by the way he he
was next to us the cops and we pulled up
to where he was and then he pulled up so
I kind of thought I could pull up
because I figured that well he's pulling
up I guess I could pull up but you know
what he's basically saying is we're
pulling up because for our own safety we
don't like people next to us because we
think you could take shots at us or
whatever which again you know we weren't
planning to do but I didn't realize that
that I know it's bad out there but I
didn't realize I didn't think he was
like um
they're gonna shoot us in a head so
we'll go up so he moved up I moved up
and then he looked it up he looked at me
and do you remember the first thing he
said I don't really remember he said sir
why did you roll through the line there
have you been drinking tonight yeah
because you've been drinking tonight I'm
like the first of all the light is green
I'm like right it's a green light so I'm
I'm going through the green light okay
that's uh how it works
and he's like well I'm gonna pull you
over to do a Dewey check and I'm like
I had exhibited no behavior of drinking
I was not swerving uh there was no smell
of marijuana or alcohol in the car
um you know there was nothing going on
we're on our way to the studio every
time I defend the cops by the way and
when I say defend the cops I just defend
the idea that there needs to be a police
force I don't really defend the cops per
se I just defend the idea that you need
to have
some enforcement of the law or rich
people just hire Mercenaries
um and then chaos ensues
but every time I even try to defend that
you know you you have interactions with
these people and they're always bad and
they're always like kind of abusive and
I'm a white guy in a nice car imagine if
I was a black guy what they could get
away with doing they bait you
into saying something disrespectful so
that they can bring you in he kept
threatening me with other first of all
we pull over okay
and you could tell he's mentally
unstable many people in the LAPD are
mentally unstable okay this is not their
first choice of employment he identified
himself as a Dre hey what was it again a
drug recognition expert a drug
recognition expert he's an expert on
recognizing when people are on drugs
because apparently that's hard to do
it's an art it's a science because you
would never know when someone's on drugs
unless you had a drug recognition expert
so lucky
so now this drug recognition expert
based on the fact that I was not
swerving not slurring no smell of
alcohol or marijuana but I was answering
his questions coherently he was like oh
he must be [ __ ] up
so he he pulls me over and then he
starts going at me he goes if you had a
drink I said not in 13 years which is
true
and he goes okay
and then I'm like he goes well we're
going to do a test here
uh and he pulls out a pen
and he goes what color is the pen now
it's a clear pen
it's a clear pen that looks bluish
purplish kind of it's a weird tint
big pen
I got I don't know Blue Clear he's like
oh he thinks he's got someone
like dummy first of all it's not even a
sobriety test the sobriety test you get
me out of the car this is like a waste
of both of our time you just want to
bait me into saying something crazy you
could bring me in and then you don't
have to do your job for the rest of the
night I get it
so this emotionally unstable lunatic uh
that has me follow the pen cap with my
eyes he's like don't move your head just
your eyes which I can do I go to laugh
you know right left right we got it
I complete that and he goes
um
you know he's kind of a Dick's being a
dick
and
I go it's rental here's the insurance
I've not had a drink in 12 years we're
going to work
he's being a dick see then he's more of
a deck starts lecturing me about D
wheezing you know whatever and this is
my job and I'm like okay but I passed
we're done
so then as he's leaving I go scumbag to
Ben because I was yelling at Ben
but here's the deal with them you can't
say to their face they'll put you in
jail but what you do is you say to
someone in the car something about them
because that's freedom of speech but if
you say to them they will say that you
are being
um uh whatever menacing threatening or
that you are uh out you know because
he's like he alluded to the fact that he
could take me in for multiple tests uh
he goes here's that's only one test
there's many tests so what he's
basically saying is say the wrong thing
I'll bring you in you'll pee in a cop
we'll do blood whatever it is you know
which then I call a million lawyers and
we go to war with piggy Blue Collar
piggy Pig but we don't want to do that
you know what I mean we don't want to do
that okay
but
uh he's uh you know drunk on his own
power uh a uh not the brightest bulb
um you know he's on on Dewey enforcement
in Beverly Hills right
um and then he comes back he goes what
was that I was like I didn't see
anything I said I have freedom of speech
it's my own car I can say whatever I
want he goes well what did you say I
said it's none of your concern and then
we just start fighting like going at it
for what about 20 minutes that's 20
minutes that 20 minutes going back and
forth with this civil servant slob about
um you know why I have rights that's all
about why I have rights and why this
idiot uh doesn't get to just you know uh
and again this is the pandemic or
whatever it is it's going back to 9 11.
it's like this is instilled and I'm like
I'm like with the city falling apart
with people getting killed smashing
grabs robberies do you think the best
use of your time right now is to argue
with a guy that we've proven is sober
and is not breaking any laws do you
think that's the best use of your time
he's like well what do you do for a
living I said I'm Gavin newsom's
personal assistant
it's exactly what I said I said that's
what I know
and we got back if I said I'm somewhat
well known I said I'm not crazy well
known compared to other people but I'm
decently well known because he goes he
said some [ __ ] about you have you ever
been shot at I'm like no I defend cops
on large platforms I've said nice things
about com I'm going to take them all
back he's like have you ever met someone
who's been the victim of a d-wee no
aren't they dead isn't that your point
he's like do you know have you ever gone
to a Dewey scene no
is that something I'm even allowed to do
am I even allowed to just go to dwee
scenes
to look at mangled people
to learn
I'm not drinking
but again the cops were abusive and
belligerent and they're trying to make
you say something they're trying to trip
you up it's incredibly unprofessional
that the way that they behave and act
and it's
sad but I was
um I you know argued my position pretty
well I said hey buddy like you know at
any time did you think I was gonna go in
yeah I thought uh I thought we weren't
getting the episode in in time for sure
well no but did you think I was thinking
I was going to jail no I didn't think
you were going to jail but I thought it
might escalate a little bit more but I
did a good job I held your ground I held
back because what the the thing is is
they're so used to just trampling on
people civil liberties and rights
um like for example I'm not drunk we've
proven I'm not drunk
I made a comment to my friend in the car
guess what it's none of your business
that I said you were a scumbag
if I say to your face I like people to
say things to my face I'm like because
you can bring him to jail that's what
you like liar
you're a liar you you're you're a power
crazed psychopath you're the entire
reason we have [ __ ] problems right
now in this country because you people
show up somewhere and start firing
wildly because you're all insane
okay not all of you but far too many
let's be clear far too many of you are
[ __ ] out there causing real problems
he's Asian guy he's like they said I was
racist
and they were spitting on me and I
didn't take them to jail I'm like number
one you probably did number two I'm not
spitting on you I'm telling you uh that
I have a right
as a human being I'm sorry that uh
doesn't sit well with you but when I
said Gavin newsom's personal assistant
the bald guy laughed yeah the other cop
on the other side yeah
baldy laughed but yeah I mean you know
what are you gonna do this is why the
LAPD I mean they're they're the most
corrupt uh police force in the country
so they don't do much but whatever they
do is always bad like whatever they get
involved with is a horrendous